après les aventures de kirikou
l'épopée d'azur et asmar
l enquête de dix lits à paris
honteuse tu vas nous raconter quelle
histoire celle que vous voulez
[Musique]
je voudrais qu'elle se passe en egypte
non au soudan non au maroc non en
auvergne ceux qui n'ont qu'une histoire
n'ont pas beaucoup d'imagination
une histoire d'abord avec une femme non
d'abord avec un homme un beau garçon
refuse de le voir ça y est ils les
trouvent et
découvrir le nouveau film de michel
ocelot en tout cas ils s'aiment ils
s'aiment même si les autres ne veulent
pas avec des costumes des bijoux avec
une paille rouge des vignettes fait mon
goûter
n'importe quoi j'aime quand les
histoires retombe sur leurs pattes
mais arrêtez elle peut pas raconter tout
ça mais si vous me donner des idées et
pour plusieurs comptes à travers trois
merveilleux conte
découvrez les aventures d'un jeune roi à
la conquête de la couronne d'égypte d'un
beau sauvage qui combat les injustices
cachés dans une forêt et d'une princesse
amoureuse d'un vendeur de beignets
c'est quoi le titre le pharaon le
sauvage et la princesse de michel ocelot
le 19 octobre au cinéma